Chelsea Handler and Heather McDonald got
into a war of words earlier this year
after Heather said on a podcast that she
lived in a fear while working on chelsea
lately and didn't agree with how Chelsea
treated the staff et caught up with the
comedian over the weekend and she gave
us an update on her relationship with
her old boss just in time for the
premiere of Chelsea's new Netflix show
will you be tuning in to Netflix next
week of course okay tell seen are good
it's all fine and you know that's what
happens when things get taken out of
context and and it's a slow we became
the we became the Real Housewives of
stand-up quite honestly that's what I
really started to feel for the girls
when I went through that week but now
we're good we've talked and we're fine
and I'm excited to see it of course we
were with Heather at a party for Real
Housewives of Orange County Star Heather
dubrow's new book I'm definitely gonna
devour it once I read it because I'm
always looking for I mean everyone wants
to look young and they know what they're
doing and they both look beautiful and
natural I think that's the way to go